hello ben hey how's it going dude we're
here
we did it we did we're both alive first
of all congratulations on your thinness
thanks slender and healthy you look good
oh thank you i appreciate it turns out
running away from my children for
four months straight will do that to you
i literally took up running just to get
away from my
children just going outside just for
some mine space
it's la man you can't get outside unless
you're actively exercising are they
coming to arrest you
oh i could alluded to [ __ ] foot locker
right then they would have that would be
okay do you run with a mask on
no does anybody yell at you no no no
what do you
go to a track like what do you do no i
literally just run around on the streets
hoping that one day i will be hunted
down by the rioters
so i don't have to go deal with my
children screaming at me but yeah that's
that's the that's the goal
did you try to get healthier when covid
hit like were you worried and
a little bit it really wasn't about
covered it was just i was eating out too
much and
when i was relegated to home it was like
i had to learn how to use the barbecue
which i never learned how to use a
barbecue actually
and then it turned out it was actually
not that hard so i don't know what i was
doing for
years i got to give you some elk meat
are you barbecuing right now
oh yeah you're still doing it yeah i'll
give you some elk sausages
you have to do kosher right so i have to
oh that's not cool at all we'll have to
go get the elk and i'll have to actually
like kill it myself
is that what you have to do you'd have
to get the elk and then you'd have to
slice its throat or something like that
oh yeah it's good times
what how that what's the logic behind
that so i mean
not too fast into the biblical stuff but
the the original logic was that you were
supposed to
kill the animal in the most humane way
was the idea now do i know if it's the
most humane way now i have no idea it's
most certainly not okay
because you have to slice it up with the
rabbis man i don't know yeah
i get it how back in the day a very
sharp knife
going through the throat would have been
the most humane way because it's almost
painless
and then the blood just sort of pours
out and that's a wrap right
you don't want the blood anyway because
you're not allowed to eat blood and
judaism so oh really yeah yeah
so what do you do when you have a medium
rare steak i mean you salt the steak
really heavily
that's why this is why kosher meat is
pretty salty so if you go to a steak
house are you allowed to go to a steak
house
uh kosher steakhouse there are kosher
steakhouses ah you're so deep in that
one no man but you're a logical
intelligent guy does part does it every
now and then i like juxtapose those
but does every now and then it [ __ ] with
your head you're like what is this
i mean of course
i don't know there's a religious person
alive i mean who doesn't eventually go
like
okay it's a little weird but all right
you got to embrace the system
but you feel like for tradition and for
just the whole
jewish culture it's worth doing exactly
i mean you
you live the lifestyle and i feel like
it ain't that big a sacrifice to eat at
particular restaurants the restaurants
are still good
they've still got good kosher
restaurants one thing that we're seeing
with society
and culture in general and one thing
that sort of does support the idea of
maintaining these sort of rigid
disciplines is that
when things start to slide just a little
you lose like a
lit these little incremental steps they
slide
and people go oh god what's the big deal
what do you care
and you're like i see where this is
going like i said there's so
this is it's going down that way this is
not gonna stop
it's sliding oh yeah and you saw it in
l.a i mean i've lived in l.a my whole
life
and the the move from la being a
pretty safe fairly nice city suburban
orientation to
just overrun with with horror shows
is really it was a lot faster than i
thought it would be but
it's sort of a you're right it's a
gradual decline and then it's just off a
cliff well you started to see
tents and you didn't see them at all
for decades and then all of a sudden i
started seeing tents i remember
i was doing fear factor in skid row in
the early 2000s we would film down there
and i'd be like this is crazy
like has anybody seen this does anybody
know this because there was these
homeless
streets like you go down these gigantic
and downtown l.a back then for people
don't live in la you would think oh
downtown's like downtown new york or
downtown cleveland
no downtown la was uh no man's land
nothing's going on in downtown l.a
it is now like there's what was
pre-covered
it was like there was some bars and
there was some really cool upscale
apartment buildings it was kind of
picking up
but uh i took my family there before
kovid like
a few four months before covert or so we
went to we we're gonna go to there's a
famous donut place there
so we said just uh one of those goofy
sunday things like what do you guys want
to do today let's go get donuts
so we went to downtown l.a like holy
[ __ ] literally [ __ ]
human [ __ ] on the streets everything
smelled like piss
bums everywhere and i'm like okay stay
close to me stay over here
if anybody comes near you move move
closer to me like jesus christ like this
is crazy i don't want him to be freaked
out but i'm like this is nuts well the
thing is that that sort of disaster area
stuff in l.a was sort of localized right
it really like i worked in the lida's
office for a summer when i was when i
was in law school it's been like 2007
says a while ago
and i remember they had a giant tent
city and you had to walk from
the car they made you park a mile away
and walk it and so you were walking
through skid row
and it's like okay well this this is
really terrible and honestly i feel bad
for these people because i don't think
the best solution for people who are
drug addicted or mentally ill is to live
on the street and a heavy percentage of
people who are homeless are drug
addicted or mentally ill
but you know is it for for people who
are living in the suburbs like this is
at least localized it's not like
reaching into your life
and then over the past 13 years like i
live in a pretty decent suburban area
and i'm seeing like open needles on the
street and walk out of my house one day
there's just a guy lying face down in
the gutter like edgar allan poe
and i thought well this is this is
falling apart rather quickly
what do you think caused the slide or
the
expansion of the slide because i agree
with you that it was very
it was very isolated skid row was very
isolated downtown l.a was very i
remember one time we were filming in
downtown l.a
and we were on a gurney or i guess
that's one of those things called
where it lifts up oh all right anyway
we're filming some fear factor stunt
and as we got up we could see people
smoke and crack
and i go look there's people smoking
crack right there and the the guests
on the show like a lot of them they fly
from all over the country and they're
like is that real
they're really smoking crack going
that's crack that's a homeless person
smoking crack
welcome to l.a it's right there but i
didn't feel bad about it i felt like
look
it's unfortunate but this is not like
indicative of all of la
we're just in a shitty spot because it's
really cheap to film here right here you
go
you know you got a little gift you get
to see some weird [ __ ] while you're here
but
i didn't i didn't think it was ever
going to get to the point where you're
on
like winnetka off the 101 and there's 80
[ __ ] tents and they put a porta potty
there they put a port-a-potty
we're doing real building and real
development here in los angeles
not apartment buildings we got some
porta-potties we put every underpass
shall have a port-a-potty
thanks to mayor eric garcetti you pay
attention to
politics far more than i do and and law
enforcement and all that
what happened how did it get to this
well on this particular problem this
actually started with a bunch of
lawsuits so the lapd used to have the
authority to move people's [ __ ] if it
was on the sidewalk
if people had a bunch of stuff that was
on the sidewalk and they're just camping
out there the lapd could come they could
take their stuff away
and they could rouse them or they could
arrest them for trespass or for
loitering
and then the aclu actually sued and they
said that this is a violation of
people's personal property
oh and the courts tell you you do such
good work sometimes and the court's
ruled that you actually are not allowed
to move people's stuff that that's
actually personal property
even though it's in a public area and
then they got a ruling from a court that
you're allowed to live in your car
because for a while you weren't allowed
to live in your car and then it was
you're allowed to live in your car
so now you're basically allowed to leave
your stuff on the sidewalk and the
police are not allowed to move it
and you're allowed to live in your car
and then
there was this sort of equity movement
that said okay well things do it in
business districts but
why can't they do it in like more
suburban areas why can't they just move
into nicer areas after all if there's
misery it should be equally spread
across the city
and and that's kind of what you're
seeing i mean this is there have been so
many breaking points over the last year
in the city and for me
for me and my wife i mean we looked at
the rioting and they shut down the
entire city at 6 p.m it's a county of 12
million people
and they shut down the entire county so
that douche bags could run around
shattering windows pretending that they
were standing up for social justice
they shut down beverly hills at then
rodeo drive 1pm
1pm so that people could run up and down
rodeo drive talking about how capitalism
sucks while
tweeting from their iphone while
stealing stealing nikes
you know there was two moments where i
was like this is a real opportunity for
us to come together and one of them was
the moment the lockdown happened
it it felt to me very similar to right
after 9 11 where everybody was
confronted with their own mortality
like holy [ __ ] like we we
might be on the verge of a pandemic like
in a movie
where a lot of the people we know die
and here
we we have to be kind to each other we
have to be this is what's important
family is important
and i remember thinking i've never been
closer to my family
never been closer to my friends we're
calling each other all the time we were
it was like it was a there was there was
real hope in that i was like if
we get through this we're going to be
tighter we're going to know what means
something what counts
[ __ ] stand up comedy [ __ ] everything
else man
what's important is love and friendship
then it started to get angry
it only took like three or four weeks
where people started getting
like they were scared so people started
getting shittier with each other online
and then i basically swore off twitter i
was like this is just too
toxic and too hostile the second moment
where i thought we had the opportunity
to come together was george floyd
so george floyd died and all of a sudden
you have these black lives pro matter
protests and and i'm like
maybe we can finally make a dent on
racism maybe we can finally make a dent
in police brutality maybe this is a
moment where we can come together
and realize what's important is
community solidarity that
we we we're all in this together like
this is crazy and then the cops need to
be reformed like they can't live like
and maybe we should take into into
account ptsd maybe we should take into
account the fact that these [ __ ] guys
are
pulling up on people every day that
might shoot them in the face they might
never be able to see their family and
their kids
let's rework this let's think this [ __ ]
through
nope then chaos and then all of a sudden
it became like
what we saw yesterday where they're
breaking into amazon
go in seattle like that [ __ ] guy
owns the washington post he owns the
most
left-wing newspaper in america and
you're like not good enough well you saw
they set up a
like a fake guillotine outside of
beethoven's house in washington dc it's
insane and
it's it's just it's madness i'm too rich
i totally agree with you by the way like
when
when the when covet happened i thought i
can't really see how we're going to
split in partisan fashion over this
thing right like
everybody wants to live and everybody
would also like to eventually get back
to regular life
and the better we can live the better we
can get back to regular life so it seems
like
okay we're on board when it came to the
lockdowns the original lockdowns i was
like okay i'm on board you know i'm
taking this thing really seriously i've
got parents in there in their 60s i feel
like
you know i'm in good health i'm fairly
young i'm 36
but for my parents i don't want my
parents getting this thing and so we're
still taking this thing real seriously i
mean i'm still wearing a mask around to
public places and i think people should
i think that's a responsible thing to do
but it immediately turned into who can
we blame for this who can we blame
who's doing it wrong and it seems like
there are only like a couple
of things that you really can do that
are obviously wrong like nobody has a
good solution on this thing okay it
ravaged
italy it ravaged spain it ravaged new
york like
there are a couple things you shouldn't
do don't take the olds and send them
back into the nursing homes with coveted
right
that's like an obvious one but beyond
that like just staying away from each
other
and socially distancing and worrying
like this is all kind of common sensical
stuff that
people have known since the flu pandemic
event 1918 like nothing nothing has
really changed
and yet it immediately turned into who
can we blame who's who's to blame for
all these dead people maybe it's ron
desantis or maybe it's cuomo like who
who can we blame so that was terrible
and then on the floyd stuff
i had the same feelings like i don't
know a single human being who watched
that tape and didn't think okay that guy
deserves to go to jail
chalvin right the officer in that case
and the george foreign everyone and
everybody
every single person was like yeah that's
that's real bad like that's and
cops like i know tons of cops i'm
friendly with tons of cops and not one
of them was like yeah that's good police
procedure i'm glad he did that like no
one thought that
and so when people like okay we're gonna
look at police brutality maybe we'll
take a look at qualified immunity
maybe we'll take a look at police unions
and the kind of restrictive covenants
that they have with the cities and
and how we make sure that everybody
knows who the bad cops are so they can't
get hired at different places
like all those are solutions but they
quickly turn from well we don't want to
talk about solutions solutions are a bad
idea what we need to do
is we need to shout about everything we
can possibly imagine
all at once and you know what instead
let's have a conversation about like
was george washington a bad guy let's
have a conversation instead
about like just completely defunding the
police we don't have like a responsible
conversation
about things that make sense we'll talk
about like what if we just got rid of
the police
how crazy is that discussion that
discussion uh
when when people were really saying
defund the police i'm like cooler heads
will prevail
but they're going to realize and i think
they're realizing it now in new york
city
i mean new york city has had record
crime record homicides
who would have thought who would have
thought de blasio is
i mean i would have never i would have
never imagined
i would look at garcetti and go well
he's better
that's exactly right
i look at garcetti and i look at de
plasio i'm like garcetti i'll have him
over my house for dinner he's way better
so weird he's so you can have protests
but only black lives matter protests
that one that was that was a solid you
know that was that may have been the
moment when i realized that we were all
effed
right it was the moment when like we're
in the middle of a global pandemic
with hundreds of thousands of people
dead and an entire swath
of our media and health elites just
decided randomly
that if you were protesting against
lockdown you were very bad right then
you were a racist and you're going to
get people killed and you should wear a
mask and i was like well if you're pro
i sort of agree with the mask thing like
yeah okay and then
you get millions of people in the
streets yelling at each other and
breathing on each other and spitting on
each other
and you got health professionals on tv
being like well racism is a public
health threat i guess that you can do
that now it's like
what the i know people who died in the
hospital of covet and their family could
not visit them
like they literally died alone in the
hospital of covet and family could not
visit them and you're telling me
that it's deeply important that we have
like dance lines this was stuff
happening at rallies like dance lines in
the streets in new york to fight racism
that's deeply important but a daughter
being able to visit her dad before he
dies that's not important
i am but what [ __ ] i am for your
freedom to protest i'm 100
for your freedom to protest i'm also for
your freedom to go to the gym
i'm also for your freedom to go to a
comedy club if you so choose
um for your freedom to go to a
restaurant look they figured out how to
do restaurants in a lot of places the
the servers wear masks
and many of them wear face shields you
distance the tables apart from each
other you do temperature checks you take
people's names and addresses down
when they enter so that if anybody gets
sick if there's any sort of kind
and they've been able to do this no this
is right the vectors of transmission are
typically
closed areas people in solid proximity
with each other for long periods of time
yes right that that's the stuff where
people are getting this stuff and
i i i trust most americans not like some
americans would be dumb asses some
people are just dumbasses oh there's a
lot of videos
oh yes you watch youtube there's plenty
of karen's out there how sad is it if
your name is karen and you're a good
person
all the good karen's out there i'm sorry
ladies
i'm really sorry but it's like this is
i made this point online i got
shellacked for it but i was pointing out
that
most americans are wearing masks right
now bipolar data 59 of americans say
that they always wear a mask when they
leave the house
and if you look at the map of mask
wearing across the board in the places
where
there are the most cases people are
wearing masks that's not i wasn't saying
masks don't work i wear a mask i think
that
the evidence shows that they do
something and we don't know that they're
not like full protective they're
the cloth masks are not as effective as
surgical masks which are not as
effective as m95s but
wear a mask good the point that i was
making is people are acting
in fairly rational fashion meaning if
you think kovit is like around you
you're wearing a mask and you're
socially distancing so this this idea
that
gavin newsom knows best how you ought to
live your life
like i i got some trouble with that
especially because california saw the
same uptick as texas and florida and
california never opened i mean we've
been here the whole time california
never really opened well we were doing
pretty good
up until the protests yes everything
seemed like it was on an uptick the
comedy store was talking to them about
becoming an essential business and and
opening up because
they had opened up bars and they had
opened up restaurants
and they didn't really have a
designation for comedy clubs they they
sort of talked about it as a live
performance venue but then
that puts comedy clubs at the same place
as the staples center
which sounds crazy right right so like
listen we can do this we can just have
half capacity
temperature checks do it right they're
doing it right in a lot of places all
over the country
we can do this the audience has to wear
masks this is totally doable
and so they were right about to do that
and then post
this other thing is we were trying to
figure out like is it protest only i
think it's bars too
yeah the thing about bars is close talk
people are
talking yeah they're drunk and they're
on top of each other i think bars
probably have a church significant
update
lots of singing lots of lots of
vocalizing right churches and synagogues
were a main vector for this
yeah i mean but again these are all
things that are fairly common sensical
and we can agree on and yet we're
beating the hell out of each other
over this stuff and there's the
suggestion we know what to do if only we
just did it this would stop it's not
gonna stop
okay it's not gonna stop it's a very
transmissible disease we don't have a
vaccine as long as people are out there
it's going to continue to pass wear mask
if you're in close proximity with others
and that's
pretty much it the hospitals are getting
better at this thank god yes they are
and the crazy thing was that they were
saying
like the you can only protest if it's a
black lives matter protest
what about a protest for increasing your
immunity
what about a protest for educating
people to
the the the techniques and the
strategies for increasing your immune
system
it is there are they're out there and
there's no discussion about this amongst
health professionals
excuse me amongst politicians if you
listen to health professionals
people that really understand the human
body they'll tell you there's a lot of
strategies there's a lot of things you
could do first of all eliminate
alcohol eliminate caffeine eliminate
sugar
eliminate all the [ __ ] in your diet
start taking vitamin supplements get
outside get some vitamin d
get get your body healthy exercise do do
all these things
and you will increase your immune system
you increase your body's health
you don't hear a word of that all of it
is just stay inside
lock you know we have to stay apart to
keep everybody safe and
god damn the number one vector for
transmission remains the home
right that's still the number one vector
in every society is the home people
going home and giving it to each other
and
when they i remember for for me one of
the breaking points in la was
was when they decided they were going to
shut down all open
areas they're going to shut down all the
parks they're going to shut down all the
beaches and i was like what is this well
not only that it goes against science
because
there's been papers that have been
studied that show that this virus dies
almost instantaneously when it's exposed
to sunlight or even artificial sunlight
yeah none of it makes any sense but it
does feel like bottom line there were a
bunch of gaps in american society
and then a bad thing happened and all
everything just sort of fell apart it
was sort of like a house of cards and
then
there's a little bit of weight put right
on top of the house of cards and
everything just collapsed in on itself
well people are panicking you know
they're getting scared and then the
economy's collapsing
so the economy collapsing at the same
time as the george floyd protests
led people to start looting and then
people that didn't give a
[ __ ] about george floyd or black lives
matter were just stealing [ __ ]
and then this police was letting them
steal [ __ ] they were standing down in
beverly hills and santa monica literally
cops standing there while people are
saying i gotta say the media coverage of
this stuff is just awful
the media were cheering this stuff on
and they were simultaneously making two
arguments that conflict with each other
one was these are mostly peaceful
protests first of all mostly peaceful is
the most
it's it's the loosest most loosely
defined arbitrarily applied term in
history
simpson was mostly peaceful that night
oj simpson was mostly peaceful that
night for like an hour 15 he was really
not peaceful but for the other
hours between sunset and sunrise he was
unbelievably peaceful like i've never
heard this term before where
a protest turns into a vast riot you
know wrecking all of melrose
and everybody's like well it was mostly
peaceful what what is that
what is that true so how about this how
about you either say
that the protesters and looters are two
different groups of people and we treat
them differently if you're protesting
that's first amendment activity the
minute you shatter a store window you go
to jail
right that's the way they should run or
alternatively
if it's if you're saying they're the
same group then they need to be treated
as law breakers so
i i believe the first i believe you're a
protester you should be protesting if
you're a looter and a rioter
then you should go to jail but the media
refused to make that distinction and
then they act like the cops are the bad
guys when they come in to to arrest
people
who are violating the laws i think it's
in portland right now they're trying to
burn down the damn courthouse yeah and
the and the feds come in and start
arresting people and people like this is
the gestapo it's like
okay speaking as one of the tribe let me
say this is not like the gestapo
okay like the gestapo was not famous for
rolling up on people and then
charging them and then if they didn't
have a charge releasing them that wasn't
like the gestapo's thing
i'm sorry but you decided that you want
to throw a fire bomb at the federal
courthouse
and your local mayor said he wasn't
going to let the police do anything and
so dhs came in and arrested you
tough [ __ ] i mean like i'm sorry that's
at some point somebody's got to restore
some semblance of law and order here
well it's it's a weird situation because
i don't
exactly understand why they're attacking
the courthouse
i don't exactly understand why they're
smashing the windows at amazon go
it's it's steve martin right they think
they must hate these paint cans
really from the jerk right but it's
it's it went from this to
literally tear down the structure of
society
well this is where we get into sort of
the deep philosophy point and this is
this is actually really
the the biggest problem right now on the
racism point is the shifting definition
of racism
so i had the unfortunate experience of
actually reading one of the best-selling
books in the country robin d'angelo's
white fragility
and let me just tell you a greater pile
of horseshit has never been produced by
a bevy of horses
it is an awful book and it is basically
rooted in the same theory as ibrahim
kendy's how to be an anti-racist
the the basic definition of racism
changes in this theory so racism
you and i were sitting here discussing
racism and the way i define racism is
probably the same way you define racism
you believe in the inferiority or
superiority of a group based on race of
an individual based on their membership
in that group too right that would be
racism
i believe that you're inferior or you're
superior based on your race end of story
right that's that's racist
so robin d'angelo and ibram kendi
redefine racism to mean
any societal structure that results
in a racial inequality is itself racist
so any structure
that results in a not exact proportion
between whites and blacks does that make
the nba racist
exactly exactly the answer is kind of
yes except that
the nba is not racist because obviously
it benefits black people right i mean
now
the nba is not racist in except it's
because it's meritocracy it's the reason
the nba is not racist
but robin d'angelo and kendy both
suggest that meritocracy is an aspect of
whiteness
they say that meritocracy and individual
are aspects of whiteness because
these institutions things like
meritocracy and individualism
and not seeing people's colors these
just reinforce hierarchies that end
with disparate outcomes and so what they
say is in order to be anti-racist
you have to want to tear down the entire
system they literally say this i'm not
i'm not
really i know that i'm not
misidentifying the argument because
again i've read their books the the
basic notion
that to be anti-racist you have to tear
down free markets
or you have to tear down free speech or
you have to and what that means is of
course
that any time there's rioting and
looting that's really just an expression
of outrage at the broader american
system
and so it justifies that sort of stuff
this is why you saw nicole hannah jones
the de facto editor of the
new york times 1619 project lady
tweeting out that she appreciated the
people were calling these the 16 19
riots
because once you say america is rooted
in slavery and rooted in evil in a
terrible horrible no good very bad place
then robbing a shop is just the latest
iteration of you fighting the system
explain the 1619 correlation to people
if you would sure so the 1619 project is
is something put forward by the new york
times
it's not good history there are four
pulitzer prize-winning historians who
said this is not good history
the basic argument is the united states
was not founded in 1776 with the
principles of the declaration of
independence
the count the country was actually
founded in 1619 with the importation of
african slaves to american shores
because that's when the first african
slave arrived in the united states was
1619.
so the idea is that the entire history
of america
is a history of a system that is
endemically white supremacist
and that all of the declaration of
independence is basically a lie that the
principles of all men are created equal
that was a lie when it was written and
it's a lie now
that the idea that we have rights that
pre-exist government that's a lie
all of these things are lies the
constitution was built in order to
enshrine white supremacy
and no evolution has taken place so they
they essentially make the argument
that from 1619 to 2020 is a continuum
racism has gone underground a little bit
but it's still there and it's still
it's still implicit in all of our
systems so the 1619 project has essays
blaming
literally everything on racism so
disparities in maternal mortality
between black women and white women
which by the way exist in europe and in
canada
that's due to american racism traffic
patterns in the united states
is due to systematic american racism
every racial disparity
is attributable to a system that was
rooted in slavery
now the traditional notion of america
that america was founded in 1776
and that the story of america is that
america did tolerate
the great original sin of slavery up
until the civil war and then
tolerated jim crow up until the civil
rights movement of the 1960s and that is
a great stain and a blood on america but
the story of america is trying to
fulfill the promises of the declaration
of independence over time make those
promises available to everybody
and this isn't my argument this is
martin luther king jr's argument when he
talks on
in the march in washington about
fulfilling the promissory note of the
declaration of independence he says
we're here to cash the check right you
issued us the check and then you didn't
let black americans be americans
we're here to cash the check is the
argument frederick douglass the freed
slave makes in 1852
makes a famous speech before slavery is
ended he says july 4th doesn't mean
anything to black americans
because we're not included in the
bargain include us in the bargain
the story of america is the declaration
of independence those principles that we
should all basically
still agree on because they're pretty
good principles free speech
free assembly all the things you see in
the constitution
that those things brought about greater
freedom and prosperity than anything
else and helped us overcome
the sins that are present in all human
societies and were present in the united
states in extreme ways as well
but that's that's the counter-narrative
right the 16-19 project says
that all that was basically nonsense and
that america's just a history of
whites keeping blacks down and that no
progress has essentially been made if
there is progress it's mostly a lie
and so every disparity now can be
attributed to historic disparities
between white and black
is there middle ground d so
if we look at 1776 and we look at the
declaration of independence and we look
at america today in 2020
there clearly is some impact
in the echoes of slavery and then after
that jim crow there's clearly
some impact in these deeply impoverished
communities that don't seem to advance
yes so the to to make the argument about
institutional racism
there's a couple ways you can read this
when people say systemic racism or
institutional racism
i usually ask them to be a little more
specific in what they mean because there
are a few ways you can read that one is
history has impact of course that's true
right that's true for everybody
it's true in your family history if you
have a grandfather who
went to who went to prison on a
particular charge that leads to poverty
for your parents which led to more
poverty for you right
people have histories those histories
are embedded in their life experiences
and that's true for societies as well
all of that is for sure true
then there's the question as to whether
the institutions today are racist
and that's not quite the same thing
right because history has consequences
is not the same thing as saying the
rules today are racist
because the rules today are not racist
actually the rules today are quite not
racist
so but historically it's fairly recent
if you go from the civil rights movement
to 2020 we're really not talking about
that much time
it's about three generations 50 plus
years 60 years yeah
i mean it's 50 plus right in the world
of you know
in the best span of human history it's
not a very small amount of time right
so clearly there's some impact of both
racism
and then jim crow laws so that that's
where i'm saying there's a middle ground
yeah
and it's independent it is important for
people on my side of the conservatives
to
acknowledge and recognize the importance
of of history in people's living
situations now
and it's important for people on the
other side of the aisle to at the same
time not attribute every single thing
to history because right but people who
are bullies something like that
there's always like extremes on each
position
and the truth lies somewhere in the
middle yeah but i don't think that it
lies as far
in in the dead center of that as people
i think want it to
what i mean by that is the problems that
have plagued communities in the united
states not just the black community in
the united states but problems of racism
or problems of sexism
the way those get alleviated is people
making better choices over time
right that is the problem that's the way
that those issues get alleviated when
jews arrived in the united states in the
in the early 20th century to talk of my
people
when they when they came they were
impoverished they didn't speak the
language
they were banned from country clubs
there was open discrimination against
them they were banned from harvard right
harvard law school had quotas on jews
the the way to fight against that is to
make
good decisions and so the you fight
against the system to make sure that the
system has
rules that apply equally to everyone
right but you clearly see that there's a
big difference between people coming
over here willingly
and doing so in order to better their
lives versus someone
whose ancestors were dragged over here
to be sold as property
and then dealing with the repercussions
of that being your family history
and redline laws and all the other
things that were put in place to sort of
keep them in very specific areas which
to this day remain crime-ridden
gang-ridden
deeply impoverished communities well
that's true but the question is how much
of that is historic redlining and how
much of that is an 18 year old kid today
deciding to pipe a gun and shoot
somebody but how much of that 18 year
old kid today
deciding to pick up a gun and shoot
somebody is based on him
growing up in this [ __ ] up environment
where that's what he models where
everything around him is crime
and gangs and you imitate your
atmosphere which what all humans do
right but the answer is there's only one
way to break that chain what what way is
that
that way is to not pick up a gun and
shoot somebody i think that's a
simplistic
way of looking at it if you're on the
outside of that community and you're not
one of those 18 year old kids that grows
up
with the incredible influence of all the
people around him and that's all you see
and that's all you know well but the
problem is the only way that's going to
be
the thing that your kid doesn't know is
for you not to do it at some point
personal agency has to come in some
it does because the expectation
education and and teaching them
about personal agency and and letting
them
understand that there's a way out of
this and that the path that they see
being replicated over and over again by
these people that wind up dying young
that wind up going to jail
that there are other options there's a
lot of kids that never get that other
information or if they get it
they get little blips of it but the vast
majority of the information the vast
majority of the influence they get is
terrible well
i totally agree with this and this is
why i think the worst thing that you can
say to a kid
is you're born behind the eight ball and
no matter what you do you're not gonna
succeed
right that's literally the worst thing
you can say to a kid what you should be
saying is look at how your grandfather
was born behind the eightfall and look
how hard he had to work
in order to get ahead and look at all
the options that's true though but if
your grandfather
wasn't ahead didn't get ahead if your
grandfather
was in and out of jail if your father
was in and out of jail everyone around
you is like that
if there's literally no influence that's
positive in your life
the idea of saying to a kid like that
hey don't pick up a gun and shoot
somebody
it's way that's way too simplistic a
version
of of their future in my mind i mean the
problem is i don't see an alternative
solution
i think an alternative solution is there
has to be some sort of
large-scale intervention in these
communities to do something
about what what what has already been
set in motion and the momentum that
keeps continuing decade after decade
i don't know what could be done well but
that's the problem is that i think that
a lot of the solutions that have been
proposed have already been tried meaning
okay so for example lbj thought that the
way to alleviate a lot of these
inequalities was the war on poverty
and he openly talked about this he
talked about he gave a speech very
famously in which he said we're trying
to guarantee equality
of outcome not just equality of
opportunity equality of outcome
and you can't hold the race where
somebody is starting 20 yards behind
and then fire the gun and say okay
that's an equal race right so you have
to get the person who's 20 yards behind
to actually get up to the starting lines
that they're equal
and so the idea was we're going to fight
this war in poverty and alleviate
poverty
largely through transfer payments and
and through the government taking a
forcible step
in favor of alleviating people's lives
we've now spent 22 trillion dollars in
the war on poverty
and we have about the same number of
black americans living under the poverty
line as we're living under the poverty
line
by the late 70s the the the real issues
that that are inter
that are creating intergenerational
poverty everyone knows this but remains
true
the number one predictor of
intergenerational poverty in the united
states remains single motherhood
the single motherhood rate in the black
community was 20 in 1960 it is upward of
70
today that's not unique to the black
community by the way it's true in the
white community as well the five five
percent
of white kids were born out of wedlock
in 1960 today is upward of 40 percent
that is not something has happened and
it is not
a matter of increased racism that's not
happening because of increased racism
right that is happening because there's
been a
cultural change that does not place
tremendous emphasis for black or white
or for anybody
on personal responsibility and personal
agency there needs to be a mindset
change
we do this by the way in all other areas
of american life except for
the most important decisions in the area
of sports nobody does this routine
and there is a point shelby steele makes
in the area of sports if a kid is not
does not have a good jump shot nobody
says to him you know what you don't have
a good jump shot because your father
didn't have a good jump shot his
grandfather didn't have a good jump shot
and the game is
biased against you we say okay if you
want to be on the team you're going to
have to learn to shoot a jump shot
right that that sounds harsh that sounds
bad but sports are different
and here's why sports are different
because sports you enter them
independently of your culture
you you you base what you're trying to
do
on the parameters of the rules and the
people that you're competing against
that's how you look at it so you
whatever culture you're from
you you walk into this new thing with
this very rigid set of rules
i don't think white people are good or
asians have a monopoly on valuing
education or monopoly on hard work or
punctuality or anything i think that
black people
have exactly the the same capacity as
any
people of any other race to do all of
these things and those are the
preconditions for success you either
meet them or you don't i mean
that's true for everybody but don't for
success but don't you think
that a lot of that is predicated on the
environment that you develop in
and the people that you're around and
the lives that you imitate
and the influences that you have around
you someone has to do something to
influence those kids in a different way
look i was very fortunate when i was
young that i discovered martial arts and
it
kept me from being what i could have
potentially been
a bad kid like it gave me something to
focus on
there's and i didn't grow up in a bad
environment but it wasn't the best
there's a lot of people out there that
grow up in horrific environments and
they never
have that thing they never have
something they they don't have a father
around
or they don't have a mother around or
whatever whatever bad
influences they have are overwhelming
and they
they don't it's it's very difficult
for someone to just air quotes get their
[ __ ] together it's very difficult for
sure that's why
to this day there's so many books about
losing weight
don't you think everybody wants to lose
weight that's fat they do they everybody
who's fat wants to be thin
they do but it's [ __ ] hard for sure
and that's nothing
in comparison to changing your whole
life but but you would say about
somebody losing weight you know what's
not useful here is lamenting
how bad your family has had it with
regard to losing weight like at a
certain point if you want to lose the
weight you got to figure out a way to
lose the weight that's true
this is based on the information that i
have i have this vast
scope of information that i've been able
to absorb if you're in these isolated
environments and
everyone around you is involved in gangs
and crime and drugs
it's very difficult to model yourself
after something that you don't see in
real life
so totally true totally true and that's
why again more information needs to get
into areas
i agree with a lot of the opportunities
that need to be provided by
education getting people to be educated
outside their local public school would
be a good change i mean being able to
like move outside your crap local public
schools
would be good the best influences for
kids that grow up in these environments
seem to be
people that have gotten out and then
come back and talk to them
right and tell them how to do it but
none of this can be done but to go back
to the original conversation none of
this has to do
with telling kids that you live in an
evil country that's seeking to keep you
down
well maybe not but there there has been
a very small amount of emphasis placed
on
taking these impoverished communities
and figure out how to engineer them out
of this situation
that's true so i don't think that's true
yeah i mean the amount that we've spent
on a federal level and a state level
on educational programs and poverty
programs over time
but on a year-to-year level i mean these
are these are enormous quantities of
money this is not a mon
this is not really a money problem it
really is not a money problem in just
terms of
you could sign everybody a check
tomorrow right the predicate so the the
predicate for the
slavery reparations movement is exactly
this sign everybody a 80 thousand dollar
check
and the problem will be alleviated no it
won't i don't think that's i don't think
i think they'll spend 80 000 and they'll
be right back where they started from
but i do think that there is
an argument that there can be some way
of engineering whether it's community
centers or education or doing something
differently in these places
to chip away at this problem so on that
stuff we totally agree
the only point that i'm making about the
16 19 project is when you teach people
that they are the victims of a society
it makes it very difficult for them to
succeed the story of black america
should be a story
of unbelievably brave people triumphing
over systems that sucked
right i mean that that is the story of
black america most black americans do
not live under the poverty line in the
united states
there's a huge black middle class
there's a black upper class yes there is
let's
let's simplify this if we can sure if
ben shapiro is the king of the world
how do you fix baltimore how do you fix
detroit how do you fix
the south side of chicago okay so here's
the unpopular view but it happens to be
empirically correct the first thing you
have to do is you have to load the place
of the police
you got to load the place of the police
because you have to stop crime once you
stop crime
then businesses are happy to invest in
those areas you're not going to get
businesses to invest in those areas and
provide jobs unless the crime is gone
you need in fact one of the reasons that
you have such a vast differential in
racial crime in the united states is
because of white racism
and there's a point that jane levy
writer for the la times has made and she
writes a book called ghetto side and she
points out
that the reason that black crime was so
high in the early 20th century and late
19th century
is because basically white communities
said to black communities you're on your
own
right enjoy and so the crime rates ended
up spiking because there were no police
there
you have to make sure that law abiding
people are protected that law abiding
businesses are protected that people
want to live there that people want to
invest there
you have to have a re-establishment of
faith in churches right you need social
institutions outside of government that
are promoting things
like family you need you need more one
of the reasons you need more companies
in these areas
is they can offer educational
opportunities to kids internships
deals to go to college and then come
back and work for us for a couple of
years
right you need opportunity the same way
that opportunity is built anywhere else
on earth you need to
provide a safe space for business to
work and for free speech to flourish
and for education to be valued you need
to go in you need to make clear to every
kid
if you graduate high school then you
will have a shot at college which by the
way is
100 true today if you are a black kid
and you graduate high school with any
level of achievement
you will have a very solid shot of at
least going to a community college and
if you score per
even decently on the sats of going to a
very high level college right
affirmative action programs are
extraordinarily common
across the united states but the the
first message is
we are going to ensure that law and
order prevail here a safe space for life
liberty and property
and ownership of private property and we
are going to make sure that you as a law
abiding citizen have the opportunity to
succeed because
the biggest obstacle to young black kids
growing up in the inner city again
is not history it is in the moment the
drugs the crime
the fact that there are no fathers in a
lot of these areas roland fryer black
professor at harvard he's done excellent
work
showing that actually the number one
factor in allowing
kids to to rise is not even having a
father in the home it's how many fathers
there are generally in a community
so you can you can have a single mom but
if there are a lot of other male
father figures around that helps fill in
the gap right these are practical things
giving kids the ability to pick the
school they go to so they don't have to
go to the local crappy public school if
it's a local crappy public school
it would be a solution here but this all
starts with the notion that
it is not racist in the slightest to
suggest that law and order have to
prevail
and that law-abiding people should be
protected in their exercise of their
rights
i think you're 100 right on that and i
think although that might be
an unpopular opinion i agree with you i
think that is very important
now what do you do in this environment
when you look at the way people distrust
the police now
in particular i mean i mean i've been
reading stories about
cops going to five guys burgers and they
can't get served because people won't
serve cops
and this idea that all cops are bad and
this is a
very really disturbing perspective to me
because
you're seeing what's happening right now
in chicago you're seeing what's
happening right now in new york where
you have this massive uptick
in violent crime because it's perceived
that the police presence has been
diminished greatly so how do
you reaffirm the trust
in in in law enforcement and what do you
do to reform law enforcement because
clearly
there are some people that are cops that
should not be cops yes there are a few
things that you can do right off the bat
and that people
right left and center have sort of
talked about and one of them is that you
can abridge qualified immunity in
certain areas so qualified immunity is
the idea that you're not liable to civil
suit
if you don't do something bad that has
specifically had a precedent
in law so you could do something bad but
as long as nobody else has done the same
exact bad thing before you're not
subjected to civil liability
you could you could experience it it's a
little complicated it's a qualified
immunity
generally means that if i do something
bad then as a police officer if i act
within the scope of my general
reasonable authority you can't sue me
for it
the actual way they do something bad
what if you shoot somebody while you're
operating like right so so the the
reason that qualified immunity as
currently understood under supreme court
doctrine
is too broad is because that the
standard used to be
you would have to act as a reasonable
police officer if you acted as a
reasonable police
officer and you took a reasonable action
right somebody went for their waistband
they had an object in there you didn't
know if it was a gun you shot them
right you wouldn't presumably be
suitable because that's
still reasonable you track a guy down
you shoot him in the back you know
and then you plant the gun on him that
presumably would be suitable right he'd
be personally liable
so the the the the way that supreme
court has done this is they broadened
qualified immunity
to such an extent that you can still
bottom line you can still get away with
some bad stuff
and not be sued for it so that needs to
be curbed that's one thing second
police union contracts need to be
utterly redone across the country
police union contracts right now protect
a lot of bad cops right because the
police unions are designed to protect
the members
the members of the union just like any
other union yeah and so what that means
is that police unions i'm not a fan of
public sector unions generally
um but police unions need to be abridged
in their ability to protect cops who do
something wrong
third you need to have a national
registry of cops who are disciplined
for violation of procedure so that they
can't just leave
lapd and then go work for a ferguson pd
right or something those are some easy
things that you could do
right off the bat but the biggest thing
right now the biggest factor in terms of
lack of faith between police and and
citizens
really is the media because there's been
a lot of talk about the
racial constituency of police forces the
the majority of the lapd is minority the
majority of the baltimore pd
is minority i believe that a huge
percentage of the of the chicago pd
is minority so it really is not about
you know lots of white cops in black
neighborhoods in baltimore it's a lot of
black cops in black neighborhoods
and that has not solved the problem of
people mistrusting the police on an
endemic level
well it's an inherently difficult job a
it's a rotten job man i mean i've
i have nothing but for for good cops
those they're heroes and the vast
majority of cops are good cops and
they're heroes yeah i read
uh a a meme the other day that's very
accurate it said if you have
a 130 good cops and 12 cops
you have or 12 cops that are bad you
have 12 bad cops if you have 130
good cops and 12 bad cops but the 130
won't do anything about the 12 bad cops
you've got 142 bad cops yeah
and i think that that's right i think
that's right i i think that it is also
true
that our standard of what constitutes a
bad cop has
in some ways become much more stringent
so for example
there are cases that become national
stories in which a cop was labeled a bad
cop it wasn't a bad cop
right but there are bad cops for sure
look look here's a great example
the the cops that pushed down that old
man and and where was it buffalo new
york is that where it was yep
granted yep that's [ __ ] crazy i mean
and that's
white on white crime right i mean uh is
a white guy
pushes this old man down and
the most bonkers part about that was the
way the president reacted like oh the
way he felt sam
seemed funny maybe he was antifa yeah
maybe he was undercover like
there was literally the worst possible
reaction
to watching an elderly senior citizen
get pushed down by a young
strong man you mean president trump had
the worst possible reaction to a thing
worse
yeah i mean unknown president trump
having bad reactions look i'm i'm a big
supporter of law enforcement i have a
lot of friends that are cops i know a
lot of friends
a lot of people from martial arts that
are cops from the ufc
i know a lot of cops from jiu jitsu i
knew a lot of cops growing up from
all the different martial arts
disciplines that i engaged in a lot of
cops get involved in that
there's a lot of good cops there's a lot
of good people out there but it is a
[ __ ] insane job and
so many of them have ptsd for sure and
but
i will say that one of the great myths
is that the big threat to the black
community in the united states is law
enforcement it's just nonsense
it's not only nonsense it's
counterproductive nonsense and you're
seeing it but it is a plan right
it is a threat off all these times it is
on a data level an extraordinarily small
threat
law enforcement law enforcement is a
threat to black life on a generalized
level is extraordinarily small the
washington post database last year
showed a grand total of 15
black americans shot unarmed across the
united states in a country of 42 million
black people the problem is
when it happens it doesn't matter what
the statistics are if people see that
video
and that video gets shared 200 million
times it looks like there's 200 million
white cops killing a black guy well and
this is why i say that the media's
treatment of this stuff is just horrific
it's not just the media it's
it's social media social social media
has blown this stuff up
and it's gotten to the point where if
you say that's a horrible situation
that's also an anecdotal situation
here's some data
if you present the data it's like well
you're are you ignoring people's lived
experiences that's racist how can you
present the data the data is
the data doesn't take into account the
full story nobody takes into account an
awful lot of the story which is why it's
called data
right like i just don't anecdotal
evidence
is evidence of an anecdote it is not
evidence of a broad national trend nor
is it evidence
that taking a broad national policy like
cutting back funding to the police in a
time of rising crime
is a good idea because you saw a video
on youtube i'm sorry
that's a terrible idea but when you look
at these videos
the positive side if there is any
positive side
is that it's they're accountable now
and this has been going on forever if
you talk to people that are black that
grew up in
in poverty stricken areas
they will tell you horrific stories
about being abused by cops
and i think the number is like 25
percent more likely
a black person or brown person getting
any sort of interaction with a cop is 25
more likely to become physical or for
them to be abused
that's that's real right when you look
at the statistics of
them being killed yeah white people get
killed more by cops
than black people but there's way more
white people no no even on a percentage
basis when
you have to use the control group of
crime you can't use the control group of
raw population
so you have to look at people who are in
situations where a deadly
interaction is likely there have been
multiple studies that show that black
people are not in more danger of being
shot by cops than white people but
it is true that low-level uses of force
between cops and black people are worse
than low-level uses of force between
cops and white people right that's the
role in friar study
there are a few confounds that have yet
to be sort of worked out i think
probably white people are
less likely to believe that the cops
gonna kill them whereas black people are
probably convinced the cops going to
kill them that might
that might play a factor in why there's
more white people being killed by cops i
mean that may very well be true it may
also be that low-level uses of force is
maybe
of force may be disparate if you think
that the cops likely to be a racist
then you might be more likely to resist
the cop and then he might be more likely
to rough you up so
it's it's very difficult to rub out the
confounds there the one thing that we
know for sure
is that the greatest threat to black
life just like the greatest threat to
white life
is members of your own race killing you
like if you're talking about actual
murders
white people are killed by white people
black people are killed by black people
by people you know
mostly right it's intraracial right
there is there there's very little
interracial crime like black on white or
white on black in the united states
there's a lot of intra-racial crimes a
lot of white people victimizing white
people and black people victimizing
black people
and the question is how do you stop that
this is why i don't know if you saw this
interview it was kind of an amazing
interview terry crews the actor yeah he
was on with uh his own don lemon
right and don lemon uh is doing the
black lives matter
sloganing and terry crews says well all
lives matter
and don lemon says but no black lives
matter doesn't mean all black lives
matter
right but terry crews said all black
lives matter and he said no no not all
black lives matter only black lives
matter we're only talking about police
brutality right now
and terry crews was like why aren't we
talking about all black lives matter
because
if black lives matter means you withdraw
cops and withdrawing cops means more
dead black people
then why wouldn't those lives matter too
and
this is where the slogan nearing gets in
the way of
actual progress because that's where
ideology hits facts right
exactly it gets very weird and terry
crews was called
some terrible names for that but then a
video surfaced of don lemon from 2013
chastising sounds like me on that right
he sounds like me he talks he sounds
exactly like you it's hilarious pull
your pants up get your [ __ ] together
you know like he's literally saying
things like don't have babies out of
wedlock
right stay in school which by the way
again all of this is commonsensical and
true for all races it is not just black
people
young white people in appalachia need to
get their [ __ ] together yes everybody
needs to get their [ __ ] together but
again young white people in appalachia
are dealing with the same thing what's
around them all the time is crime
people taking pills everyone having
babies out of wedlock
people impoverished no hope no
no potential for escape i mean
that i agree but the first thing that
has to change the firs so my dad had a
when i was you know looking to get
married my dad said the way that you get
married
is it's not that you find a girl and
then you decide to get married you
decide to get married and then you find
a girl
meaning that you you have to sort of
make up your mind that you're in that
you're in the mode
of this might be where we disagree the
most
a good way to get hooked up with the
wrong lady bro well you make the life
decision that you're at that point in
your life when you want to make a
decision
along those lines get married when you
love a girl so much you're willing to do
something so
[ __ ] stupid that you're willing to
get married to her because
getting married to her is how is where
we're going to get married less
painful to you than the idea of losing
that person
because i look i think marriage
the good thing about it is that there's
financial
protection for the family financial
particularly when there's children
involved i think that's when it's the
most important thing
you know i think financial protection
for the children look
i grew up without child support my
father was a deadbeat dad
so i know what it's like to be poor
because your father doesn't support you
i think that's horrific i've seen it in
many situations i know many people that
have been the victim of this
it's disgusting there are a lot of
shitty men out there
that don't take care of their kids white
black
asian it's universal that
needs i think that is where the legal
definition of marriage
and protection of children and
protection of the woman who has to take
care of these children financially
i think that's significant when it comes
to
bringing the state in to
somehow another solidify your love like
you know i love you you love me but
let's bring in a bunch of [ __ ] people
we don't know and write it down on paper
that's nonsense well i totally agree
with that obviously but the point that
i'm making is that
when you want to make a change in your
life you first have to commit that you
want to make the change before you make
the change well sometimes you meet
someone that's why you want to make a
change no they attempt for them
okay so not to get into marital advice
here but like
but i have some you know i've been
married for for 12 years at this point
thank god very happy marriage we have
three kids
and the the reason that i say you have
to make up your mind that you want to
get married before you get married
is because you look for a different set
of factors then if you are if you are
if you make up your mind you want to get
married what you're going to look for is
commonality of values who is the person
you want to build your life with
do you share interest you share a vision
for the future
whereas if you sort of fall into it then
you can fall in love with somebody you
don't share any of these things with and
it makes it a lot more difficult later
on to actually don't think they'll like
true i don't think you fall in love with
someone that you don't share
values with i think you you think
they're hot and you want to [ __ ] them
people makes this stuff up pretty
regularly well people are silly people
are indeed silly people do
people tattoo their eyeballs ben they do
a lot of dumb [ __ ]
you live in a world i don't man that's
not my world
i don't have any friends with eyeballs
tattooed but people
make mistakes with they get attracted to
someone physically
and you know particularly men are and i
guess women too i'm just not one of them
are attracted oftentimes by people they
think are sexy
but are a bad choice in terms of a life
partner
right but i don't think you fall in love
with those people they just become
how many times you married a girl just
because they thought they were hot
a lot a lot a lot men period
it's not just jews like the drug of
sexual attraction
is the most sold drug in the united
states it it sells
cars it sells homes it's literally it
sells
lifestyles pornography yeah but that
what is that i mean when you're seeing a
woman with a short skirt on and long
legs
walking like like lustfully around a car
what do you what is she what are you
saying you're saying if you buy this car
maybe you can [ __ ] this girl
that's what you're saying well of course
the worst [ __ ] false advertising we
have in america but
this is why when it comes to marriage i
think that it's important to actually
put your large head before before your
other one uh you know the
jonathan height in his book his book
called the happiness hypothesis great
book
terrific right he and he talks about
this right he talks about the fact that
people make a very large scale mistake
about marriage which is they think that
the passion you feel at the very
beginning is what you're going to feel
40 years in and that's not the way this
works it starts off
where your passionate love level for
somebody meaning like lust and how much
you want to get them in bed and how much
you want to be with them all the time
is it like 100 and your and your level
of
kind of committed love right that level
of love where you have
shared values that matters to you like
this much and then over time after about
like two years the passionate love
starts to decline
and by the time you're 60 then you
better have shared values because
after 60 years it ain't going to be like
it was when you were 20. right so
you have to have in mind what things are
going to be like a few years down the
road which is why i say you should be
thinking about
what your life together is going to be
like before you fall into bed together
that's
sound advice but well at sea that's why
i disagree
because i don't think there's anything
wrong with falling into bed with someone
that you're not going to live the rest
of your life with
that's where you and i probably disagree
yeah i mean i think that it is a bad
idea
generally and again i think that it is a
bad idea because
there's a lot of people out there that
have had some really good times with
those bad ideas
and it may be that when i die i look
back and that is one of my great regrets
my friend but
let me just say that that i think that
the
the the thing that that has been forgone
uh is in my life at least more than made
up for by the relationship that i have
with my wife
so i can i'll go anecdotal there but i
also will i'll go data driven which is
the longer you live together with
somebody before you get married the
higher divorce rate after
so that's the higher the divorce rate
after if you live for a long time with
somebody and then you get married
there is a higher percentage chance you
will end up divorcing that's interesting
i wonder why that is
probably because of the open window
syndrome like people feel like okay i
lived with you for three years why
aren't we married yet
why aren't we married yet because the
guy's like oh the window is still open
and so
they're still completely committed so
once the guy does sign off she's like
why didn't you do this five years ago
well there's some of that and also it
feels like everybody kind of settled
right like if it was if it was i'm so
committed to this i want to get married
right now
maybe they just did mushrooms together
and realize they really love each other
again different world man
you know y'all i have a different
experience from everybody else i dated
my wife for for
three months we got engaged we were
married within 10 months we married for
12 years we're both versions when we're
married so we're old school
it clearly works for you i've tried to
be open-minded with basically every kind
of way that people live their lives
including like couples that live with
other couples and they wife swap
which is i feel like that's complicated
i mean i'll be honest it's complicated i
always think those people are trying to
i i know people that do that and i
almost universally believe that they are
distracting themselves from their life
they distract themselves from either
their career they're fulfilling the
potential
whether it's as an artist or as a
creative person
or as a person who's pursuing a
discipline i really believe that a lot
of times when people
complicate their lives with multiple sex
partners and a lot of times what they're
doing is they're doing it
they're distracting themselves and they
don't realize it at the time
that just keeps getting pulled into this
direction pulled in that direction
it's because you don't have a primary
focus on something that's very important
to you
yes you know and it doesn't mean that
you have to be with this person for the
rest of your life
it doesn't mean you have to only be with
one person but when i see a guy
that is you know involved in swinging or
something like that and
then they're balancing a bunch of
different gals trust me
that you that you're going to waste time
man you know there's not enough time in
this life i mean
it's weird to tie this whole
conversation together but it is true
that if you want to be good at a thing
or be successful at a thing you have to
commit to the thing yes and so that's
true whether you're talking marriage
it's true whether you're talking
educational success whether you're
talking career and people
you know making bad decisions because
distractions are distractions
distractions and distractions with every
discipline and i think relationships are
a discipline
in a lot of ways i totally agree yeah i
mean and it is true that
you know you have to make the the
pre-investment and you have to you have
to make the commitment that you're going
to continue to invest in the
relationship as
time goes on yeah and then that's where
people fall off the wagon it's why i see
a lot of divorces around year three
right as that passionate love kind of
goes down and the companion and love is
the name of the term when the companion
love starts to rise
people are like well yeah but the
companion loving is much fun is the
passion to love
like of course not of course that's just
the way it works well that's nature's
biological trick
the ultimate biological trick is like
look when we were monkeys
hiding from eagles okay you had to [ __ ]
as much as you could and
and spread that seed around because you
likely only had five or six years on
this earth
right and you're dead at age 32. yeah
you were trying to just get as much of
your dna out there as you possibly could
that's still inside of us that program
is still inside of us
and that program is when you see a man
and he's with a beautiful woman but
another beautiful woman walks by he's
like looking at her and thinking maybe
maybe i can do better that's a thing
that is programmed into your dna
but you have to understand what that is
if you're a man and you understand what
that is
you go oh this is nature and it's dirty
little trick
dirty little trick trying to get me to
spread my seed
brett weinstein he illuminated
this in a really interesting way he was
saying to me
what's the difference between beautiful
and hot and i said uh
i don't know what is the difference he's
like beautiful is someone who you look
at you're like wow
that person looks beautiful that's
lovely they have a beautiful face or
wonderful eyes they look great
hot is someone who's wearing like a
short skirt
and their tits are popping out and you
look at that person you go this is an
opportunity for to spread my dna with no
commitment
and that's what that is that's that's
the pull and hot
that kind of hot is what's sold that
cheap
quick fast food sort of thing that's
what porn is
porn is all hot porn is not beautiful
it's not i don't think porn's bad either
but porn is
all hot it's all dirty girls it's all
your stepmom
your dad's off playing golf it's that
kind of [ __ ] you know
it's it's like you you know you you're
the pizza guy you show up and
two girls are having a pillow fight yeah
exactly it's your it's your lizard brain
versus your prefrontal cortex exactly
yeah it's your monkey brain it's that
that monkey that wants to hide from the
eagle
that's what it is it's like it's like
huh i could just do this real quick and
across the board you're gonna you're
gonna have a
a better life it may not be a hotter
life but you're gonna have a better life
if you use the prefrontal cortex a
little more often
yes unless you're hugh hefner i don't
know if he he had a good life or not
he seemed i know some people who worked
with him near the end yeah you seem kind
of miserable
i mean towards the end i'm sure he's
miserable he's an 80 year old guy
hanging out with 20 year olds
what the [ __ ] do you have to say to
these people right it's like you were
talking about with o.j simpson o.j
simpson
had a mostly peaceful mostly peaceful
day
well his life is mostly annoying the
time that he gets to [ __ ] them
when you're 80 years old you only get to
[ __ ] those 24 year olds for like
how long can he last once every six
weeks what do you think well he's on
probably all kinds of drugs that keep
his dick hard but i would imagine
like he couldn't run on a treadmill for
20 minutes
right right at that age so how is he
gonna have sex for 20 minutes
so if he even if he's having sex like
it's probably exhausting
and the rest of the day he's just
listening to them talk about tick-tock
and all kinds of other stupid [ __ ] he's
like
he's like remember when frank sinatra
was here and we were banging everything
inside and he's like those were the good
old days
i was wearing a robe i had a pipe we
were having fun on a tv show
i had my own channel he had a playboy
channel for a while
yeah i think it's the image
of it is way more interesting than the
actual
act of living that life yep and i think
that again
that that goes back to you know every
bad decision people make is is tied into
this is the the image of things looks
way better than the actuality of things
it's true in politics it's true in love
it's true it's drawn a lot of things
yeah
and so you actually have to look at the
actuality of things and you don't want
to be an 80 year old guy i live with
five
24 year old girls you just don't
that guy lived in hell i guarantee you i
bet his life was mostly annoying but
every now and then while he's having sex
with those 24 year olds he's probably
like i can't believe this is real
for that 30 seconds yeah i can't believe
this perfect body and i
get to like with this wrinkly sack of
rocks
that he has as a body he gets to have
sex with this
beautiful perfect specimen of a of a
female human being
and then she's like buy me stuff and
he's like god this is all he has to do
you make me famous yeah yeah worked out
great
well you know the grotto the by the end
it seemed like it was pretty dingy
dude i went there i i really did a
marijuana policy
project uh thing there once and uh
of course sounds like a lot of policy it
sounds like a lot of policy
but one of the things he did was like we
were wandering around it's like an aei
summit you know it's like
when i go to heritage foundation it's
what it sounds like right there
it was it was a fun night well i would i
remember
you know it was there was a lot of
marijuana smoked it was
quite a blurry evening but i remember
thinking like my god this grotto is so
outdated
like it had like a [ __ ] old ass phone
there and
like i'm like how much how many people
[ __ ] in here like how weird is there
just generations of
human residue in here yeah yeah and
maybe not like the best times either you
know
it's like a lot of it it's it's just
it's what you think it is versus what it
is
you know yep well you know it's all
working out of life
it is let's work on on thinking about
what things are rather than what we
would like them to be because
accepting reality is a hard one
accepting reality is a real tough one
yeah that's a problem it's a problem
with advertising too right because
advertising
shows you and social media yeah right
social media is well that's another
jonathan height book the coddling of the
american mind which is amazing
and it is really illuminates and um i'm
waiting for my kids to read it i think
maybe this year is a good
time for my 12 year old just to
understand that this is
this is a real issue with children that
are
comparing their lives to these fa oh
here's a here's an example
i wanted to show you something i haven't
actually put this up anywhere
but this is actually important because
this is so
goddamn crazy i want to show you
something
um this is something that uh
my daughter did uh
this is my daughter is ten
okay that's her
look at that oh my god that's not a
ten-year-old you're right
it's not 10. it's like a 20 year old
right there exactly how's that possible
how's that my 10 year old daughter oh
she would watch a youtube makeup
tutorial or something
she used a [ __ ] app she used an app
that turned
her into it turned her into a woman
like what the [ __ ] is that so like when
you're you're seeing things like that
what is that how are they doing that and
who's doing that so
if you're a girl and you are overweight
or you have you don't like the structure
of your face
or you know whatever is bothering you
you have acne
and you see a girl like that and she's
she's like
can't believe i'm graduating high school
lol what do i do now
and you see this that's not even her
right this is my 10 year old she doesn't
look anything like that
like she showed she's like daddy look
this is what i look like i go that is
not what you look like
i mean what the [ __ ] you just did that's
not what you look like
and so i had her go through this with me
and show me what she did
i'm like show me how you did this like
what are you doing she's using some
weird app like
like was it khloe kardashian the one who
changed her whole head
yeah yeah yeah that like you know this
it's such a recipe for failure
it really is it's such a recipe for
failure because you're always going to
fall short of that
and it's one thing to shoot for better
it's another thing to shoot for the
unobtainable and then be
upset when you can never reach the
unattainable but it's sick
it's it's sick because you're these
people don't even
look like that and then you look at that
and you go
why don't i look like that like they
don't even look like that
right the amount of people that actually
look like that that
that image that i just showed you is so
small
and it's so unattainable and then it has
broader societal ramifications because
then it turns into
stories about well okay well society
doesn't accept me for the way that i am
society values that look and that means
society is flawed and it's like well how
about this how about like
people are flawed society's flawed
you're flawed do the best you can
everything is flawed everything is
flawed but that's not even really what
the problem is
what the problem is we've created a
technology that we're not
equipped to manage we're not equipped to
navigate
social media we didn't grow up with it
we didn't evolve with it
this is something it's involving us now
no it's true it's 100 i mean they've
built these apps that are specifically
designed to be addictive right i mean
they're specifically designed to prey on
certain parts of your brain that are
you're not really in control of that are
mostly subconscious
and that is scary stuff for sure i mean
you can be manipulated by by that stuff
it's you can make people very very
easily very easily
my kids my kids aren't getting like i
seriously will not give them a
smartphone until they're probably
mid-teens late teens will they get a gun
first probably
probably yeah
[Laughter]
i feel like it's better logic i mean i'd
rather that my 13 year old know how to
shoot than my 13 year old how to browse
porn
yes i think that is good logic you know
what's it really that's a real issue
with boys
uh boys that have access instantaneously
i mean if you give a
phone you're basically saying here
little fella go watch people [ __ ]
they're gonna that's the first thing
they're gonna do when you're not around
and there are all sorts of studies that
demonstrate that this leads to
relationship and sexual insufficiency
later and it ain't good it ain't good i
mean this is not an argument to ban porn
or anything but like
the way that it has integrated into so
many really young people's lives i'm
talking like young teens
right what percentage of american males
do you think are addicted to porn at
this point it's a giant
it's got to be 50 right i mean it's got
to be extraordinarily high percentage
and none of that is good for
relations between men and women and then
you got this weird dynamic where
it used to be that the feminist movement
sort of recognized what social
conservatives did that this is pretty
objectifying and
not necessarily great for women now and
then it's like now in sex workers which
is weird
it is weird they went completely the
other direction and i just thought in
what
what hugh hefner fantasy did women
decide that all the women at hugh
hefner's mansion were actually
super duper empowered like that does not
seem like the most super empowering
lifestyle
like you make your choices man it's a
free country but my wife's a doctor
and i feel like that's more empowering
than like getting screwed by an 80 year
old for for
you know pocket change depends on what
kind of car he buys her
mom is a doctor she can get whatever car
she damn well pleases my friend what
happened
what happened that that became like
empowerment like
how did what where was this i think
there was a shift and it's a shift
that's happened throughout american
society
that went from the notion
that men were acting like pigs and they
should stop acting like pigs
to what if everybody acted like pigs and
so instead of just
saying that standards exist and people
don't live up to them but the standards
are actually not a bad thing
we just decided you know what we don't
want to be hypocrites we're getting rid
of all standards whatsoever
everybody shouldn't have standards and
if you believe that anybody should have
standards then you're a hypocrite and
when all the standards go then
everything goes
so like i actually kind of agree with
the original feminist idea that
men were kind of acting like sexist
jackasses and they should stop that but
the solution to that was not
okay now women should imitate men at
their worst and that's a free or better
society like i just don't think that
that's
against free country do what you want on
the legislative level but as a cultural
matter i don't think that leads to a lot
of human happiness
i look at it like sexual televangelists
that's what i look at like pornography
like i think that
you should be allowed to rip people
off with a really obvious ruse
like if you're one of those late-night
people that can put hands on people
and raise them from the dead if you're
one of those people i feel like god
that's so obvious
it's almost like a good little pitfall
to have out there in society to teach
people that some folks can be deceptive
and i feel like really manipulative
women
that trick old guys into marrying them
and then take all their money i feel
like that's
that's yeah that's deserved at a certain
point you're like
okay i sign off on this come on stupid
yeah you didn't see this coming
it's like this is a great country i mean
it really is like you can make money
doing pretty much anything like when
people say it's hard to make money in
this country
there are a lot of people making money a
lot of different ways yes in this
country and i mean
for god's sake colin kaepernick is
making millions of dollars kneeling for
the national anthem it feels like and
calling america racist while cashing the
check this is a great damned country
well we're now we're getting into the
weeds
i just wanted to talk about girls
ripping dudes off i know you did but we
can go back there man
that's okay but the colin kaepernick
thing
all right don't you think that
at least some good has come out of
him doing that where it sort of
raised awareness for police brutality
just let it just put it to the forefront
let people
like let people understand that this is
a problem
no no no because i think that he made
a serious error which is that the most
positive movements in american social
history
have been ones that don't kneel for the
flag but say in the name of the flag you
should do x
right so martin luther king said in the
name of the flag civil rights are
necessary
booker t washington said the name of the
flag civil rights are necessary they
didn't say the american flag stands for
racism and jim crowley so the american
flag stands for something beyond that
live up to the american flag but here's
here's mine trashing the american flag
is like endemic of police brutality is
first of all it's [ __ ]
but second of all it's actually divisive
on an issue that does not need to be
divisive like nobody is in favor of
police brutality nor should anyone be
right here's the counterpoint why is it
trashing the american flag to take a
knee
isn't that in in some ways just another
gesture of respect like you're not
doing what everybody wants you to do
which is put your hand over your heart
but you're doing something that's also
respectful
and silent you're not standing up and
going [ __ ] the american flag
[ __ ] these people you're actually taking
it to another level of respect you're
taking a knee you're bending the knee
whether you're doing it for something
that you want to talk about later saying
i'm not going to stand up because this
is my way
of acknowledging the fact that there
have been
a lot of people that have been
mistreated by police and murdered by
police and this is how i do it this is
how i treat
racist police killing black people i i
take that moment to take a knee
like how is that so disrespectful like
how is that
any it's a just a silent gesture it's
not
uniform like it's not doing this thing
that everybody else is doing
but you're doing something that's very
respectful you're taking a knee
um well that's certainly not the way
that he intended when he first started
that way i mean if you want to interpret
that way you can
how do you know what his intention is
because he literally talked about it i
mean he said that he
wanted to highlight that right he said
but he said america
is a systemically racist country he
worked socks with pictures of cops as
pigs on them
oh yeah i don't know oh yeah i mean
colin kaepernick is a terrible
spokesperson for this moment
like again like these are there's so
many people that have
taken a knee and don't you think that
but if you just look at the gesture
itself
isn't taking a knee even more respectful
than standing with your hand over your
heart i mean
then i imagine millions of us would
routinely take a need for the american
flag i mean the idea
wouldn't if that was the thing you had
to do if the id but again this guy
decided to stand and put his hand over
his heart
really it's just it's sort of a
traditional thing we're arguing over
well
i mean it isn't the way that it was
originally expressed it sort of morphed
over time right to the point where it
doesn't necessarily mean what he
originally meant it's not like he's
going
[ __ ] you while everybody else has their
hand over their heart in silence but
he's taking a knee he he didn't mean it
as an fu i mean there's no question
that's what he meant it is
he and it wasn't even over something
that actually made sense like you
understand during the civil rights
movement
when people are raising the black power
fest at the olympics to say
like we're fighting for civil rights jim
crow is still in operation around the
country
right colin kaepernick taking the needs
to symbolize that america's police are
systemically brutal and racist
is just it's factually untrue and to
attribute that to the american flag is
really kind of nasty but he's not a
statistician right so he's looking at
things like the eric gardner case or
you know which is a terrible one right
there's
there's
cases that you see like when the guy's
just selling loose cigarettes and
they're struggling
from the store it's a terrible case you
see something like that and that
motivates him to do that
and i know what you're saying that these
are anecdotes and this doesn't
encompass the full statistics of cops
versus black men and how it what what is
exactly is happening but that's not his
area of expertise anyway he has
he has that so making him a spokesperson
for a movement where he has no expertise
is a weird thing to do
there are plenty of people who talk
about this with actual statistical right
but if you're knowledgeable
a famous person and you you decide to
take this big stand publicly like that
after you get benched for blaine gabbard
yeah i have to get bench for blaine
gabbert and take millions of bucks from
a major corporation
is that the guy yeah the immortal blaine
gabbert the hall of famer blaine gabbert
who played like no no
no blaine gabbert was an nfl quarterback
who sucked i mean he was terrible and
they they benched colin kaepernick for
him and it was after he got benched that
he started doing the kneeling for like
for the american flag i am a pretty good
gig
sports broadcaster who knows nothing
about sports
listen people try to talk to me about it
if you explain it the way that you're
explaining it meaning we're not living
up to the american flag which is why i'm
kneeling
i wouldn't be arguing with it he didn't
explain it that way that wasn't that
wasn't the way it went down
but it's just him what do you think
about god there's certain guys that like
lock arms during the american fight i
never promised that okay locking arms
okay but kneeling is bad
well no well the way that he
characterizes kneeling was bad okay
meaning like
but what about other people that neil if
they characterize it differently it
means a different thing okay
right i mean meaning like what it
originally was is what it was
i'm not gonna retcon what he meant at
the time he was the first to do it right
right and then he and then he made
millions of dollars for his bravery
again
i don't think it takes a whole hell of a
lot of bravery to be benched for blaine
gabbert take a knee
make millions of bucks from nike i wish
i could play explain gabbard
fellows terrible qb rating is all you
really need to know
not a good quarterback is the answer so
is colin kaepernick i mean i don't
as a an athlete is he not good
like he's a terrific athlete he's just
not a very good quarterback okay so i
mean he he had one fantastic season he
led the the 49ers to the super bowl and
then like a lot of kind of
one-hit wonders in sports people kind of
figured him out season two and his qb
rating started to decline
but i mean look bottom line is that the
making him the spokesperson of a
movement where he really
i don't like the idea that you are going
to attribute to all of america
a sin that is number one anecdotal in
nature
and number two cannot be attributed to
america's highest ideals you're doing it
wrong if you want to fight police
brutality
say america is not living up to her
promises say that
the promise of america like there is a
way to conv
every successful social movement in
american history has done this the gay
rights movement did this the gay rights
movement said listen
everybody in america has been guaranteed
a certain level of freedom and we're not
being guaranteed that level of freedom
right the freedom to pursue happiness is
not being guaranteed to us we're just
asking that we'd be left alone leave us
alone
and it took time but most americans came
around to that perspective the the same
thing holds true
on race the same thing holds strong
police brutality if you make an
invocation and you say to americans as
americans
i know that over time my fellow
americans are going to come to realize
that they need to live in accordance
with the fundamental principles that
founded the country
that's unifying to say that the american
flag is inherently non-unifying
is is really bad like to the point where
you now have college campuses where if
you fly an american flag
there have been cases where people are
asked to take it down because it's too
divisive like that
that's that's that that does seem crazy
when you say
it's anecdotal that you know you know
he's reacting to something that's
anecdotal but there's
many of those anecdotes and you see them
over and over again the problem is
they're so they're they're so prevalent
there's so many videos
so this is my friend joe schilling is a
kickboxer and his
entire instagram has been dedicated to
bad cops over the last few months
just showing all these videos of bad
cops i mean
yes it's anecdotal but god damn there's
a lot of anecdotes well there's 330
million police interactions every year
so
yeah i mean that's what was the initial
interaction that what was his motivation
to do that was there an
uh a single instance of police brutality
that caused him to do that trying to
remember which season he did this this
would have been
three four years ago so i'm trying to
remember i don't think it was the
michael brown situation because i
remember there were protests in the nfl
over michael brown
right which was actually a bad anecdote
like that was a bad one for people to
pick people doing the hands up don't
shoot that didn't actually happen right
he actually tried to grab the gun from
the cop he the gun went off in the car
he charged the cop
by witness testimony all the witnesses
were black you know the eric gardner one
is much cleaner right well
the eric garner one is cleaner in terms
of police brutality it's not super clean
in terms of racism or even cause of
death
so this is one of the problems police
brutality police brutality for sure it's
kind of like
it's actually you know i'm warning
people now that what happens in the
george floyd case with derek calvin
like they should be warned up front i
want this police officer punished i
think everyone wants the police officer
punished
the defense is going to make a case that
the police officer is not responsible
for
george floyd's death in exactly the same
way that the new york police officers
made the case that they were not
responsible for eric garner's death
and the autopsy the the initial autopsy
tends to support that so
what that suggests is not that derek
calvin is good or clean or decent
but if you're going to charge him with
murder that's that's a hard charge to
make just on a legal level
so i'm warning people now of that
because the the move the next move will
be
obviously the system is racist if derek
shaven doesn't get convicted of
first-degree murder
it's going to be very hard to convict
him i think you're charging him with
second it's going to be very difficult
to convince him
to charge for a second right because at
first would mean pre-meditation right
third well he was charged with third
originally and then keith ellison the ag
over there elevated it's a second degree
i think that's very difficult to make
the case for for second-degree murder
what were you pulling up jamie you had
something you want to say yeah i had the
part of when this
actually started in 2016. he started
i just keep doing that he started by
sitting
and people started getting video of him
sitting as the preseason was starting
so he then talked to a teammate they
discussed kneeling was the best thing
for him to do at the time
um do you remember do you know which
incident kind of kicked it off that's
why i was gonna play a video of it so i
had here the actual first video of him
talking about
him donating a million dollars to the
local community i think he had guns
drawn on him
which is probably what started okay but
here's him talking about that
and i've been very blessed to be in this
position and be able to make the kind of
money i do
and i have to help these people
i have to help these communities it's
not right
that they're not put in the position to
succeed
or given those opportunities to succeed
and as far as
taking the knee tonight
eric as well as myself had a long
conversation with nate boyer who
is a military vet and
we were talking to him about how can we
get the message back
on track and not take away from
the military not take away from fighting
our country
but keep the focus on what the issues
really are
and as we talked about it we came up
with taking the knee
because there are issues that still need
to be addressed and
it was also a way to try to show more
respect to the men and women that fight
for this country okay so that's better
obviously
but that's him scroll down for a second
because i think that that's his that's
2016. so here's
this one okay look at the one right
below that okay this is the one i'm
talking about
i'm not going to stand up to show pride
in a flag for a country that oppresses
black people
and people of color that's the sentence
right there so that's a different
that the video was four or five days
after these statements were made so he
said he changed
after talking to someone he made okay
right so the initial explanation is the
one that i was talking about okay so he
revised his feelings on it and then well
that's nothing much
it started with kaepernick had guns
drawn on him by cops for being one of
the only black guys in his town
yeah that seemed super reasonable what
he said there about how
having the second take after talking
about the military yeah that's better
military rather yeah although he
recently released a video that sort of
goes back to the original explanation
suggesting that america
is endemically and systemically racist
which is which is a problem that's a hot
take right now it's good
it's very popular yeah that's that's the
big one yeah that's the big one
yeah how do you think we get back on
track
how does how do we find balance i always
hope that things go
really far in one direction and then
really far in the other direction and
sort of
listen i end up in the same place i
always end up which is we gotta learn to
leave each other the f
alone i mean seriously like that's
that's the only way this is going to
work
because we either have to decide we want
to share a country and live together
with each other or
we have to decide we don't yeah if we
want to live together and share a
country
then we have to stop basically making
crazy demands of one another and this is
what the cancel culture is all about but
we
we got we got to stop that we got to
recognize that people may not agree with
you people may do things differently
than you and that's okay like
as much as i just like what colin
kaepernick's doing i don't think that
you should be blackballed from the nfl
if i were an nfl owner by the way i'd
hire him in a second you know the kind
of press i'd get for hiring colin
kaepernick
i'd make a boatload off of colin
kaepernick that's a great deal
so how come people aren't doing it um i
mean i assume
because he's not that great a
quarterback i mean like if he were tom
brady i think that he would
you know be getting a contract he also i
mean there was that whole situation last
year with kaepernick where he
where he wanted to do tryouts for the
nfl and then he sort of broke the nfl's
rules and doing the tryouts and he
wanted to film it a certain way and all
this sort of stuff but
i guess i'd backup quarterback because
here's the thing you're either going to
please
one half of the population or please the
other either he's amazing in which case
you've got a winning team and a great
story
or he gets sacked every other down in
which case half the country cheers so
controversy sells yeah that's for sure
yeah but how do we
i mean this is probably one of the most
racially divisive times in my memory
in my lifetime i don't remember things
being everybody's worried about
everything being racist every single
thing that anyone does syrup is racist
pancakes are racist oh it's it's evolved
into all the you saw this trader joe's
story
you were telling me earlier so trader
joe's is called trader joe's
right which is not racist i guess but
apparently they they
have mexican products that they were
calling trader jose's
and some bored person in their basement
decided to create a petition
that got signed by some 2400 other board
people about why it shouldn't be called
trader jose because that's racist
so apparently it's cultural
appropriation if you're trader joe's and
you make a burrito
but if you call trader jose's then
that's i i think they called it
exoticizing
mexican people-sizing yeah it's making
them exotic and other
so trader joe's pulled it down trader
joe's gonna is gonna not use this
anymore 17 year old called out
a 17 year old called out trader joe's
now the chain is dropping offensive
labeling
like how many hispanics were picketing
outside trader joe's being uh now that i
saw that trader jose beer
right listen i'm italian do you think
papa gino's is that really
you know i mean is that really an
italian who made that company like
how many how many different like
different pizza companies and all these
i would love to see italians
i'd love to see the racial breakdown of
the people who signed this petition i
would bet 90
of them are white 90 right right white
live in the suburbs hate their parents
yeah what did you say what was the word
they used for it exoticized
exoticized they said yeah oh my god that
is so adorable
exoticizing i was talking to you about
um rick bayless who's a famous chef of
mexican cuisine
who is a white man who who adores
mexican food i mean i love the guy i
love listening to his videos i love
mexican food so
watching this guy's videos it's like i
love someone who's really into something
you know i just i get a kick out of even
like there's a guy i used to watch on
pbs
that would make furniture with um
ancient tools i could use like like
ancient
like um uh different old-timey saws and
chisels and [ __ ] and he would make these
wooden chairs and tables and furniture
right but he kind of looked like that
but he was he was really dressed like an
old-timey guy
and he had this old-timey shop and he
would make this stuff and i loved
watching him and i don't give a [ __ ]
about his shitty furniture i don't but
what i cared about was the fact that
this guy was really passionate
about his thing and it was very
attractive to me and i feel the same way
and i watched this guy
rick bayless talk about mexican cuisine
he loves it he takes regular trips to
mexico and
learns how to cook these dishes in the
traditional way and then he talks about
it with this great passion
but the guy just got [ __ ] all over they
were just
like you're culturally appropriating you
shouldn't be doing this you're a
white man let me just say this generally
cultural appropriation is a bunch of
horseshit and the reason it's a bunch of
horseshit is because you know what's the
best in life
all the things that are good from ever
everybody else's culture
like the reason people live in major
cities is to go to
all the different restaurants from all
of the different cultures yeah and why
is cultural
i'm so confused as to why cultural
appropriation is bad cultural
appropriation is the greatest thing that
has ever happened to planet earth
if we're all siloed off into our own
little culture you know how much things
would suck
it would just be terrible so this kind
of yeah this kind of stuff is just crazy
it drives me nuts i look i
grew up teaching taekwondo which is a
korean martial art
i learned to count in korean i had to
speak
all the techniques in korean i hate
koreans clearly i mean that's clearly
the problem i culturally appropriated
the [ __ ] out of my childhood yeah
exactly
it's this is all this is all crazy and
there's no there's no
apparent end to it like there's no
limiting principle there's no limit
there's no limit i read a column this
morning by somebody i think it was in
the washington post
saying that we should just keep changing
the name of everything like literally
forever we should just keep changing the
name of everything she said
you know there's this town and i think i
found a non-offensive name for the town
but if i found something else that was
offensive like three years from now we
should change the name of the town
there's not a case we are living in 1984
right yo orwell talked about renaming
everything man
people will find a way they'll find a
way to be mad
well here's my here's my controversial
statement okay okay if you uh my
controversial statement is
if you have to go this far to find
things to be offended over
there's not that much to be offended
over if you have to get go so far
that you have to be offended by trader
jose's you got nothing going on in your
life
there's a dramatic demand for being
offended and acting like a victim
and they're just like they're actual
victims in this country yes and
internationally they're seriously actual
victims
yeah but we don't focus on any of those
folks right we focus instead on like the
dumbest bull crap you ever heard
you know about about renaming libraries
and listen i'm fine with you want to
move you want to take a confederate
statute and put a museum fine i mean
those guys were jerks
they're they're terrible people fine go
go for it but you're talking about
we're going to fix the world by renaming
washington dc because washington was bad
it's like what did you do lately did you
do washington did like i understand we
don't put up statues to people for all
the bad crap they did martin luther king
had a real bad record with
ladies okay we don't put up statues to
martin luther king because we were
saying he was great with with women
i think everybody was bad with women
back then everyone is bad period human
beings suck
okay so either get rid of all the
statues and recognize the human beings
obviously for sure and there are
gradations of suck do you remember back
when they were tearing down the civil
war statues and
and trump in all his wisdom was like
what are they gonna do next
what about lincoln what about uh they're
gonna take down george washington and
everybody's like oh he's so
crazy meanwhile that's exactly what
they're doing that was what they were
doing the what
i mean in chicago well actually that was
actually christopher columbus who was
legitimately a bad guy
he was i mean yes also everyone
was bad like literally all the people
were like enslavement
brutal brutal treatment of people right
fairly commonplace do you think it's
there's an argument to be said that
maybe we shouldn't celebrate those bad
people anymore that we know
what they now that we know what they
really were not really i think we should
just talk about the bad people like i
don't think we're the only good people
in history
i think they should have a statue of
genghis khan
i don't know what did genghis khan do
that was good that had good results well
he opened up trade to china okay if you
want to put up a trade to china statute
for genghis khan
federation 10 of the population yeah
true enough and
and what impregnated the other 10 or
something
everybody literally raped his way
through asia the point of a christopher
columbus statue is not all the bad
things he did to the arawaks the point
of a christopher columbus statue is we
are glad
that western civilization came to the
western hemisphere i kind of agree with
that principle
i think it is a good thing that western
civilization came to the western
hemisphere and yes there's a lot of
brutality and yes there was a lot of
cruelty we should talk about all those
things
but this notion that the only cruelty
that has ever existed in human history
came at the behest of western
civilization
that everything was a rusoli in paradise
before christopher columbus came
that christopher columbus doesn't
deserve a statue in specific
that we should that that like either
make the argument that everybody was a
product of their time and therefore no
one deserves a statue
or recognized that when there's a statue
of christopher columbus we are not
honoring how he treated the arrowwalks
no one ever thought that we put up a
statue to christopher columbus because
he was really
sweet to the natives on the other end of
that right that nobody
so what is the purpose of a statue like
when you have a christopher columbus
statue like what is the purpose of that
statue
we not we all know who he is we all know
what he did why do we have an
enormous bronze version of him in the
middle of a park
i mean presumably to say that western
civilization arriving here was
a good thing right or to have the
conversation i mean that's that's
it's a monument to a in historical event
right
right or listen columbia university is
named after columbus right
the idea of america as colombia right
which was an alternative name for
america
was after columbus because he was a
discoverer well that's a weird one right
we're we're named after amerigo vespucci
who nobody knows who the [ __ ] that guy
is yeah he's been lost in the time he's
totally been lost but
but there is this idea that has settled
in that we and it's really
of high irritation to me that we are now
the only good people who have ever lived
everyone who came before us was just a
horrible person and we are the only good
humans who have ever like
isn't the world lucky to have us we're
the only people who have ever lived who
are completely sinless and we can look
from our perch
at the top of morality at everyone who
came before us and say that those people
were all garbage compared to us now
there were people who were garbage
compared to us
but i really don't think that washington
was among the people who you can say was
garbage compared to you like i don't
think that you living in 1770 are a
better person
than george washington i think you stand
atop the legacy that george washington
hell built well i have news for those
people that were trying to break into
amazon go history is going to look back
at you like you're a piece of [ __ ] the
people in the future that would never
shatter property and never spray paint
things
and and never attack people for filming
things with their cell phones
they're going to look back at these
violent actions and they're going to
look back
and they're not going to be kind they're
the same one i mean
it's every single generation
hopefully if society doesn't implode we
don't have nuclear war
every single generation is going to
learn from the mistakes of the past and
hopefully improve
that's what we're hoping for and we
should be happy
that we can look back on a lot of these
people
and say we understand now how deeply
flawed they were and what
was wrong with george washington or
what's what was wrong
with thomas jefferson although he did
you know draft the declaration of
independence he was a slave owner
and this is one of the contradictions of
our society and our culture though we
fathered kids with a slave i mean yes
yes i mean
you don't have to shortchange the evils
of human beings in order to recognize
either the direction of american history
or recognize the good things about
people people are a little more complex
than i think we want to think of them
yes and this is one of the arenas that
this sort of gets back to the point
about the system
if you recognize that human beings are
capable of great sin and also capable of
doing great things
what you really want is a system that
that
of checks and balances that prevents
people from gaining too much power to
hurt other people
and what you also want to recognize is
that the flaws
of human beings are not necessarily the
flaws of the system and that just
changing the system is not going to
change the underlying flaws of human
beings which means you actually have to
think through the policies that you're
promulgating before you implement them
clearly if you say this
you're not paying attention to what
happened at chazz or chop
because they they had it nailed it was
paradise for a short period of time
that's one of my favorite stories of
this year because
these people basically took over this
gigantic chunk of seattle and said we're
going to show you how it's done
they wind up being the police they want
to beating the [ __ ] out of people who
did anything they didn't want them to do
including film things
they wind up see you saw murder you saw
massive graffiti you
certainly saw borders there were borders
put up they kept cops from coming in
they kept a lot of people from coming in
enough journalists the beat up
journalists they uh took over private
property so they appropriated private
property these are not buildings they
built
they didn't make a deal they didn't
barter they didn't have some sort of a a
beautiful mutually beneficial
agreement with these people that own
these buildings no [ __ ] you they took
them over they took them over and
started spray painting [ __ ] all over
them
it's crazy but it shows you like your
child-like child-like idea of
what you can do that's better you don't
take in
that you don't really understand that
the founding fathers really did put into
play
into place all these checks and balances
to keep someone
from abusing power and as much as trump
would like to overcome all that
you see time and time again he's a great
example
in in many ways of how this system
really is beautifully engineered
from 300 [ __ ] years ago because the
founders didn't understand the
the problem of human nature which is
people want power and they want to hurt
other people very often
and you still need government in order
to do things but there better be broad
scale agreement on the things you want
to do
or a small majority of people can really
hurt
a huge minority of people right this is
what they call tyranny of the mob right
they were they were much afraid of this
and and that's stuff that is worth
remembering you know the tearing down
that system because you want to build
something more beautiful
if it looks like chas or chop that ain't
a thing what's this idealistic
they have blinders on they have this
this narrow
tunnel vision view of what they think
this utopian future could be
i think they think that human beings are
going to be fundamentally transformed by
a different system yeah so they look at
the problems
one of the biggest problems we have in
american politics is the myopia with
which we look at the united states
so when you're dating somebody it's very
easy to see all the problems with the
person you're dating
when you're married to someone it's
certainly easy for my wife to see all
the problems with me and there are
plenty
but when she looks at all the other
people then she's like okay well he's
less flawed than the others right
when you look at the united states it's
very easy to see all the different flaws
in the united states because of course
they exist this is a society filled with
humans 330 million of them
but when you look abroad and you look at
other examples of civilizations over
time and then you look back at the
united states you think maybe the system
isn't quite that bad because the fact is
that for all the problems we got
the biggest problems that humanity faces
and has faced are not happening in the
united states they're happening
everywhere else china right now is
shipping
weaker muslims on trains after shaving
their heads to concentration camps where
they are being forcibly sterilized
there are actual problems on planet
earth that is not to say there aren't
problems in the united states but they
are not
the same in terms of degree and they are
not the same in terms of scope
and to pretend that the system of the
united states needs to be ripped down
from the inside
and that if you build a beautiful new
system you will shape humanity such that
we are all saints and no sinners
you're out of your mind i agree with you
and it's it's the uyghur
situation is shockingly undercovered oh
my god well it just it demonstrates that
when people said never again they were
full of crap they're just full of crap i
mean it's not true
in the the this is one area where the
united states should absolutely be
taking a leading role it is obvious that
china is a nefarious actor
china's been stealing our technology
china's the chinese government is
attempting to extend its rule of tyranny
over hong kong they just subjected 7.5
million people to their direct tyranny
in violation of trading
and the response has basically been
muted from the western world
and did you see that did you see that
video of the uh the chinese
ambassador in britain being asked on the
bbc about that tape no i didn't
it's fantastic so the bbc interviewer
shows him the tape of the people being
pushed onto trains right
and he says what is this and the chinese
ambassador says
i can't see it i'm not sure what you're
talking about he's literally saying that
the screen is huge it's right behind him
like he's looking right at it
and he acts as though he can't see it
and then he starts talking about the
natural beauty of the region
right he he he won't he won't deal with
it he won't he won't explain what it is
and the rest of the world is just like
well you know what this is where
you know in the sporting world the the
whole the story that's undercover in the
sporting world is the
is the blowback on that the nba gave to
daryl mori the the
houston rockets jam for saying free hong
kong right you can't even get anybody in
the nba to condemn china while china's
subjecting a million uyghurs to abject
slavery
mark cuban just had an exchange with uh
ted cruz the other day
where where he was going after cruz for
something and cruz said
just you know he questioned cruz cruz's
balls or something and cruz came back
and said well do you have the balls to
condemn china
and cuban said something like well you
know i don't want to
i don't want to get involved in the
internal affairs of another country i
thought well that's
that is not an internal affairs question
it's one thing to say i don't want to
get involved in the tax rates of other
countries another thing to say
shaving people's heads shipping them on
trains to concentration camps where you
force them into labor and or sterilize
them
that seems like not an internal issue
that you're not allowed to criticize
really
yeah that's a big one but the the china
thing is so crazy because so many
so many business interests have this
connection with them
and so much of the the money that they
generate
is because of china i mean the nba films
there's
there's so much so much of our culture
that kowtows to china we're so connected
to them that's one of the things that we
really found out
from this pandemic is how many things
are built there how much of our medicine
how much we rely on china
it also demonstrates the lie of the idea
that if you trade with somebody then
they're going to liberalize
yeah and that was that was something
that was pushed over the last 30 40
years real hard which is
we'll help them out economically we'll
have mutual trade it'll be good for both
of us and they'll liberalize because
once they realize it's good to be part
of the world economy then they won't be
pirates anymore instead they just took
all the chips off the table and said
no actually i'm going to double down on
this and we're going to get more
tyrannical not less i mean
she is the most powerful chinese leader
since mao it's incredible
we don't have much time you have a heart
out in one minute i just want to know
what what do you think goes down in
november and how hopeful are you for the
future
because it seems to me like we're [ __ ]
no matter who wins because the chaos
that we're seeing the civil unrest we're
seeing
it's going to either accelerate or or or
or spread one way or the other so i
think that
if we're going to hold together we have
to make a decision either fundamentally
the american system is good but flawed
we need to work on the flaws within the
system
or fundamentally the american system
sucks and was rooted in slavery and
bigotry and we need to rip down the
entire system
the latter is not really a great recipe
so we can have normal political
arguments within the former or the
country is toast
as far as what goes down in november
look right now the polling data says
trump gets gunked i mean right now the
polling data's got biden up
10 12 points in the polls but didn't the
polling data in 2016 say that hillary
was going to steamroll
on the national data nuts on the
national data they were kind of right so
on the national data the final real
clear politics poll average was like
three points hillary won by three points
in the popular vote
the state polls were really were really
wrong particularly in wisconsin and
michigan and pennsylvania
on this one because trump is universally
losing in like all the swing states and
is in spitting distance in texas
he's got a lot of ground to make up
right now listen biden is running almost
the ideal campaign he's not alive he's a
not alive person
and as it turns out beating a dead horse
is actually kind of tough
right he's like because
he's not threatening he's fundamentally
non-threatening you look at biden and
you feel threatened by i don't feel
threatened by and the man's not alive
you can't threaten me with a corpse
right and so and so trump who is
innately volatile and looking for
something to kind of attack is his own
worst enemy it's his own worst enemy
like with hillary
the untold story of 2016 is that trump
didn't win hillary lost people
hated hillary's guts and the stat that
proves it is that people who hated both
trump and hillary
broke for trump pretty heavily right now
people who don't like either biden or
trump are breaking nearly universally
for biden
because trump is so off-putting and you
know i've said for a long time politics
is about the art of making it hard to
vote for your opponent and easy to vote
for you
and trump is fairly good at number one
and he is awful he is god awful at
number two
making it easy to vote for him that
that's that's a toughy
well said well said thank you ben
shapiro always a good time man
always enjoy seeing you all right that's
it bye everybody
awesome thank you
[Music]